over 11 000 people have died as a result
of the devastating earthquake in turkey
and Syria and that number is sadly
rising and I know many families here in
the UK will be anxiously awaiting news
I'm sure I speak for the whole house in
saying our hearts go out to each and
every victim and their families and we
must do all we can to support the rescue
and Recovery efforts
Mr Speaker this house is honored to be
addressed today by president zielinski
from the outset of the war he has
symbolized the heroism the resolve and
The Bravery of his people
the Prime Minister and I joined this
house together in 2015.
we've lived through important moments in
our domestic and international politics
but none of those experiences compares
to the pain and suffering of the people
of Ukraine
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that right across this house it is vital
that we all continue to stand together
in full support of Ukraine
prime minister welcome I first join with
uh The Honorable member for paying our
respects and thoughts to the people of
turkey and Syria particularly those
affected by the earthquake and the First
Responders who are doing such a valiant
job the house will be reassured to know
that we are in touch with the Turkish
and Syrian authorities and providing all
assistants that they have required of us
including 77 search and rescue
responders that arrived yesterday and
have already begun work and I spoke to
the President yesterday to ensure that
we are in close communication and can I
Thank The Honorable gentleman for his
comments on Ukraine it's something that
not only the whole country can be proud
of but the entire house can be proud
that we came together to stand by
Ukraine when the moment mattered and
that we will continue to stand with them
United as one part Parliament and one
United Kingdom just for the record is
the right honorable Kirsten
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank the
Prime Minister for that answer because
every time Putin has been appeased he's
been back for more and so does the Prime
Minister agree with me that across this
house we must speak with one voice and
say this terrible conflict must end with
the defeat of Putin in Ukraine
of course
Mr Speaker our objective remains to
ensure a Ukrainian victory in this
conflict Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin's
aggression cannot be seen in any way to
have been successful and that's why we
have accelerated and increased our
support militarily for Ukraine this year
is the decision that I took as prime
minister today we are going even further
not just having provided Challenger
tanks from being one of the first
countries to do so which catalyze a
provision of tanks from other nations as
well but also today to move to start
training Ukrainian Marines in the
advanced capabilities they will need to
mount further offensive but also to
train their pilots on Advanced combat
aircraft so the house can be reassured
we will continue to support Ukraine to
ensure decisive military Victory on the
battlefield this year
Mr Speaker can I welcome the additional
support the Prime Minister has outlined
today I've had the privilege I'm sure he
has of seeing firsthand the brilliant
work our military is doing in Salisbury
to train ukrainians in defending
themselves we all support this work and
the UK's role in the International Drive
to ensure that Ukraine has the weapons
and the technology required to defend
herself
does the Prime Minister agree that
continuing this International effort is
the only way to ensure Putin's defeat
prime minister
Mr Speaker that the house may not all be
aware that actually we have continued to
train Ukrainian soldiers because it's
something that we have done for years
before the conflict started and
something that we should be very proud
of but obviously we've intensified those
efforts last year we trained 10 000
Ukrainian soldiers through operation
interflex this year the defense
secretary announced that last year we'll
be training 20 000 uh Ukrainian soldiers
in addition to the Marines and Air Force
pilots that I mentioned earlier but the
Rival gentleman is right to highlight
this has been an international effort
one thing that is a mark of UK
leadership in this particular area is
that around a dozen other countries have
all come here to the Ukraine to the UK
to take part in our training programs to
support Ukrainian soldiers many people
many members from around this house all
have visited in their constituencies
that effort it's something that's making
an incredible difference on the ground
and I know something that the president
zielinski is incredibly grateful for
I think the whole house would like to
thank those is involved in the
incredible training that is going on Mr
Speaker before I entered this house I
had responsibility for fighting for
justice in The Hague for victims of
Serbian aggression
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that when the war in Ukraine is over
Putin and all his cronies must stand at
the Hague and face Justice
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker
is absolutely right that we must hold
those to account for the horrific crimes
that they have committed I'm proud that
the United Kingdom has played again a
leadership role in this regard being one
of the first countries to provide
financial and Technical Support putting
investigators on the ground we're surely
to be hosting a conference together with
the Dutch and also one of the things I
discussed with President zelenski this
morning is our support for the work of
the ICC where thanks to the efforts of
UK members I'm hopeful that we will see
the first indictments very shortly
Mr Speaker across this house we don't
just hope for Ukraine's Victory we
believe in it
and part of that Victory must be
Ukraine's reconstruction does the Prime
Minister agree with me that Russia
should pay for the destruction it has
caused through the well-flying dormant
in blocked Russian government assets
prime minister Mr Speaker we are the
third largest humanitarian economic
donor to Ukraine 1.4 billion pounds of
support that we have provided through
direct Grant assistance and guarantees
that multilateral lending organizations
and again the house will remember we
took a lead in imposing economic
sanctions on Russian entities including
individuals and state sanctioned assets
we've ensured the provision of funds
here will be put in a foundation for
reconstruction in Ukraine and we are
currently working with International
Partners through the legal process to
use those assets to fund Ukrainian
reconstruction of course that's
something that we all want to see and
we're working with our partners to
achieve that yeah
thank you Mr Speaker as a country we've
always been at our best when we stand up
to tyrannical aggressors threatening
their neighbors and peace on our
continent
that's why the labor party helped found
NATO and why our commitment to Nato is
as unshakable today as it was back then
the Prime Minister agree with me
whatever differences we may have
no matter what difficulties we face as a
country
we in this house have a duty to stand on
the shoulders of giants who came before
us and support Ukraine's Fight For
Freedom Liberty and victory
prime minister Mr Speaker we Remain the
leading European Ally in NATO as we
always have done we continue to increase
funding in our Armed Forces by 24
billion pounds at the last spending
review to ensure that we make maintain
not just our NATO obligation to spend
two percent of our GDP on defense but
also we participate in every NATO
operation and remain the leading Nation
when it comes to contributions to NATO's
rapid response force and the NATO
Readiness initiative but I joined with
the retinal gentleman in saying that
this house and this country Will Stand
United with the with the Ukraine until
we ensure the defeat of Vladimir Putin's
unprovoked unsanctioned aggression and
that we will make sure that Ukraine is
not only Victorious but that we bring
peace to its people